[Music]
zach do you have a an all-time favorite
moment that you just
when you hear the audience you're like
yes
i mean i i always look forward to the
turn um
i'm a big fan of justin's measuring uh
sequence
um and then of course when my name comes
up at the end i get a special little
flutter but uh
no no i i'm yeah it's hard to pick my my
favorites yeah i love that none of these
characters i don't think i've ever seen
a horror movie they're just like
i'm going to measure the square footage
i'm going to keep exploring i remember
doing that and thinking what is he going
to do with all this footage why why
why the and it it's he crafted he was
also deliberate that's right i
questioned
um while we were shooting it it was so
um
he he makes it all work so
well it was so funny so that was
unexpectedly funny for me yeah let's
back it up all the way up where this
idea began when did it start for you
zack
um
i had read a book uh called the gift of
fear by a security consultant named
gavin debecker and there was a chapter
in the book that is was it was uh
well it was encouraging women to pay
attention to those like little tiny
almost invisible red flags that men can
throw up in day-to-day situations and
they were things that were seemingly
innocuous but they were they belied a
much more sinister intent so for example
when a man compliments you uh when you
didn't ask for it or touches you even in
a non-sexual way when it's inappropriate
um or injects does you a favor that you
didn't ask for all of these are like
little red flags and he's saying you
know society has
has uh encouraged women to ignore a lot
of these red flags so that they don't
seem difficult or so that they're not a
[ __ ] or something like that so i was
reading this chapter and i just
i had this realization that like i
i don't think about this ever at all in
my life because i don't have to because
i don't have to look at half the
population as like a potential threat
um and so i didn't want to write a movie
i just wanted you know it was late at
night one night at my
in my garage and i just started writing
like a scene where i wanted to load as
many of these uh seemingly invisible red
flags into one interaction and so i
thought of the idea of a double-booked
airbnb as a place you know where i could
i could do that and so
um you know him touching her luggage you
know making her tea she didn't want all
of these are saying pretty name like
that's not appropriate and a lot of guys
wouldn't notice that but i think that
more women would
um and so i just wanted to kind of play
with with that theme with this and then
as i was going i just was enjoying
myself and kind of i didn't know what
was going to happen and i was pretty
sure he was a bad guy and then you know
i got them down into the into the bowels
and i was like all right so at some
point he's got to do the thing that i
you know think he's probably going to do
and i was like [ __ ] i hate this like
every if i know what's coming the
audience knows what's coming
and then i was just like uh and uh a
giant naked lady comes out and smashes
his head and i was like that's oh that's
fun well now i [ __ ] now i like it but
it's over
still in the bowels though what was that
you're still in the bowels filling the
bowels yeah um and so then it was about
exploring that theme of like um
sexual aggression and sexual threat uh
from the exact opposite angle and so
that's why i i came with that character
and um who is just wreaking havoc and
completely oblivious to the damage that
he does
and um and i wanted them both to kind of
pass through the same i'm talking a lot
i wanted them both to pass through the
same you know moral test uh and you know
she passes and he fails
right yeah that's where it was so the
first character we meet is tess uh
georgina when you were reading the
script for the first time what what was
the moment where you were like ah i'm in
um i think from the get-go i kind of was
reading the script and thought this is a
really well-written script and then i
think as
you know when you watch it you have that
moment of when it moves and suddenly
you're in aj's world and you're with
justin i remember reading that and being
like what the [ __ ] is happening like
where am i what's going on and then i
kept reading and reading and reading and
it was just so
well written and it was so uh
interesting to read and i was gripped
and i couldn't stop and that's usually
you know when you're reading scripts if
that's how you feel when you read it
normally if nothing terrible happens
that's how you should feel when you
watch it definitely and and justin for
you i mean i i i'm speaking for
everybody but hollywood's sweetheart was
there any
you're speaking for no one
guys you know just speaking for my
mother was there any hesitation to kind
of play this role where he's he's an
[ __ ] no the opposite i really
relished the the idea of doing something
like that and um
it was that like georgina said so just
so well it was so gripping um
i i i thought it was a romantic it
started it starts as a romantic comedy
and so i thought i was reading it that
way so i i felt like well this is a
really um which is they're hard to write
they're it's hard to write people
liking each other you know um and like
meet cute sort of stuff and so i thought
like well that is so well written um and
it works on that level and
then when the
mother came out of the darkness i just
uh i i i
was blown away you know i wasn't
expecting it at all and i was in a van i
was in a i was driving a little camper
van across the country and i was reading
it in um i stopped at a like a truck
stop rv park it's like polite to call it
an rv park um and it was in in louisiana
in the middle of louisiana
and and so it was like the setting for a
horror movie already and i was reading
it and i was so
conflicted because it was so gripping
and and i really wanted to know what
happened next but it was also so scary
and there were weird noises going on
outside and 43 year old man was afraid
to sleep in the
in a van and so um i put it down for the
night but i was thinking about it all
night i want to know how it ends i don't
know what happens so i had to read it i
had to finish it the next morning in the
with the daylight yeah
speaking of mother is his mother among
us
oh there there she is
take a bath stand up take a bath this is
matthew davis our mother
what a joy what a joy to say you're here
in this room
do you want to do you want him to come
come come come come come out come matt
come on down get him up here
what a guy what a joy
yes oh thank you
[Applause]
yes
look at the freak everybody
you never know who will show up
would you like to
[Applause]
[Music]
so how was uh breastfeeding justin long
just a dream thank you yeah i was gentle
uh now you use a lot of teeth you
latched immediately recall there there
was a crazier scene that got that
should i not bring this up every time
there was a more uh scene that um
after the breastfeeding the
breastfeeding scene uh the getting to
know you scene um
uh you
matthew's character sees a uh a rat it's
trying it needs to feed me because i'm a
i'm a baby and i need
nourishment and a little rat is screwing
along and and she grabs it kindly and
bites the head off as you would and
emasticates it and then
like baby birds it into my mouth
[Laughter]
we had we had to lose it we had
what was the uh what was the mother
makeup process and and how long did it
take
uh they got it down to three hours
and uh yeah it was a face piece and a
boobs piece and a crotch piece how did
how did that feel
uh it felt felt great yeah
uh
yeah it was weird walking around naked
but i got got used to it and it was
strange we all got used to it
yeah i never got used to it
yeah georgina and justin like i feel
like it's cliche to be like what was it
like on set where was it scary but like
when you just sitting there in the
mother costume like
eating crap you managed to
kind
of you know put the two uh apart and
obviously when we were filming it was
you know matthew's amazing and it was
very scary and like very much you're in
it but obviously if he's eating a panini
then uh it's just matthew
great paninis in bulgaria by the way it
was ha i was hard to separate i i
thought at first i might have to like do
uh some sort of methody thing and avoid
matthew and just kind of like because it
was i'd so much i had to be in so much
fear of him uh and he's such a nice
person as you can see
but then it just got to be too
complicated and so we were and matthew
was very sweet he would like kind of
take care of me while and you know while
we were doing these wild scenes because
there's a lot of
you know they're intense scenes but it
was
so funny so i need to say like at the
end of these scenes where he's like ah
he goes so are you okay sorry
yeah how you doing
well i'm sure you all have some
questions so if you do go ahead and put
your hand up and uh get to as many as
possible i see you two right here so
we'll do you in the glasses first and
then next year
yeah i'm a giant horror fan yeah um
i'm i'm interested in it it's probably
not going to be exclusively all i'm i'm
interested in but i would be more than
happy to do another horror movie soon
yeah
yeah so the question is about the the
location the neighborhood how did we do
the different looks with it um so we
actually filmed this in bulgaria uh and
so that was a field that had a road um
against a long one-story laboratory uh
and so we built 13 facades uh on that
field and so i was actually very very
self-conscious because i don't know if
anyone noticed but like across the
street from our hero house we built
these facades against the wall of the
laboratory and so in between the houses
you can like see that wall and i was
like we're [ __ ] i mean it looks like
[ __ ] like it's it's ruined the movie and
i don't think anybody's said anything to
me about that so it's fine um and then
we were able to
uh you know
be very specific about what we would see
in the 80s flashback and make those
surfaces and those a lot of the grass is
cg but like pretty much everything else
is like you know just rebuilt or like
polished
and then when she's driving through
detroit and walking through detroit
that's in detroit we went to brightmoor
and we filmed we filmed that there
going back to you being a horror fan are
there any horror influences that you
feel are present in this film
uh i
auditioned the takashi mike
movie was like a big
i'd say that's maybe
the spiritual ancestor of this um
you know psycho with the with the
unique sort of act structure uh then
dragged me to hell uh with just like his
his camera sam raimi's camera movement
is just like amazing and so um yeah that
i said this to you outside of the q a
for for justin at the end when mother's
kind of taking your eyes out it took me
right back to that final shot of jeepers
creepers and i thought it was a
reference but he said it wasn't i
actually had not seen jeepers creepers
uh well oh well
zachary yeah
the exit's there i'll be here okay um
but i saw it i saw it after i cast you
but i just said because i told him about
it and i was like when i called george
to tell her that you were
she's like jeepers thanks georgie
[Laughter]
all right we'll take some more questions
straight back there yep you question for
georgina uh how did you approach the
acting uh and sort of act two from the
pit onward as you know
oh uh yeah i think um
from the pit onwards i guess i like i
knew that was coming and the approach
was
just feeling
what it would be like to be in a pit for
that long and uh everything was you know
very well written it was there there was
there you know and and then i just got
to kind of play and and hang out with
justin and it all came together well i
hope
what was that set like did you build
like tunnels and
yeah i mean they were amazing in
bulgaria i have to say like the the the
house interior was on a stage uh the
basement was on stage the tunnels were
on a stage you know that that that
staircase that you look down that long
one i mean we that was a 30 meter
uh staircase that we built and so it was
all very uh it was all practical and
when you turn the lights off you know
she was in total darkness so it was it
was very easy i would i would i don't
want to speak for you but it was easy to
get into the zone of those scenes
because it's it's it was scary in there
yeah it was really really scary and very
dark and like very horrible so it was
yeah it was very easy to get
right here in the front
uh the question was once keith had his
head bashed in a very disturbing
question in the front row wants to know
how the body was disposed of
in a way that right is that what you're
saying
if one were to do that if one were to
replicate that with maybe with a smaller
animal is that what you're saying okay
what do you think happened to the body
well uh you'd have to
build another tunnel
yeah
i think they probably had a i think they
probably have a room where the bodies go
in i think that's what most serial
killers do they have a place with a
berry and it's been like you clearly
haven't been to a lot of dungeons and
that's okay
they buy a lot of lime from costco you
know to bury the bodies
really good taking system mother could
probably was probably a hell of a digger
i don't want to speak for you
i don't know what do you think that's
it's it's a good question
it's a great question
yeah
well if
it's been a couple of weeks though it's
been a while it's been a while we went
down there so there's been time for
cleanup
but you still want to know where she's
not satisfied acid a vat of acid
yeah i have some more questions i like
how many people did mother kill like how
often is that airbnb booked is that all
right that's right
i think opportunistic about it yeah i'm
not gonna answer okay unfair
that's fine i see hands straight up in
the air we'll explore all of it in the
sequel
so mother superhuman strength i mean
she's pretty strong in a few of those
scenes and a little bit that jason i
think she's dead she's coming back any
comments on that
for me no
[Laughter]
oh uh you know we trimmed some stuff uh
which was which was you know the right
thing to do i i didn't have any uh
any meddling you know whatsoever so
i'm this is it this is the director's
cut i'm happy with it um some things had
to go for time there were some things
that that i really loved that just um
like for example the rat scene the only
reason i had to go is because i just you
don't want to see too much of the mother
you know too soon and so the more that
we can kind of just keep her
a mystery the better and you there's no
way to get around she bites a rat you're
getting a good look at her it is what it
is so that had to go uh there's a couple
of other scenes here and there that that
were chopped but um it's it's all for
the best
yeah
um we'll go you in the red shirt yeah
um i've like been a zombie in a
commercial and i've you know been a
a yeah a random creature in a
like a nickelodeon tv show or like the
alien xenomorph in a sketch for cordon
or that kind of thing but all of those
were like
one day in the makeup and doing it and
then getting out of it and you're like i
did that and so the difference for doing
my first creature
feature
is uh
is that i was like oh my gosh how am i
gonna sustain this kind of thing uh for
multiple days and
i mean i was there for five weeks and
only shot 12 days over five weeks but it
all led up to five days in a row at the
end and so i was like okay
it's gonna have to
will i be able to do it five days in a
row and um
and i did
[Laughter]
one thing i noticed this time around
that i that in the credits there are
some names that
i adore some names i know are there some
cameos that we should be looking out for
or listening for
well there's one
justin
yeah you're saying no way zach you have
to do it
well now i feel bad she said no way but
uh
the the lovely and talented kate
bosworth is is uh aj's agent on the
phone melissa gilbert bad news she's
here cameo and she did a great job
um
who else my wife uh sarah paxton is uh
makes a couple of voice things here
she's the voice of the tv and she's uh
she's on the phone and a couple other
spots those are the two i noticed okay
cool i see one right there in the light
yeah when you saw there was a whole
movie called nope were you like they
stole my line
um
well so i'm actually friends with jordan
and i i went to his house and showed him
the movie a few months ago and when that
when we were done i was like so tell me
dude like is that scene where she says
nope like is that gonna be a problem and
he was like no it's great no it's great
i was like he said no do you do that in
your because i knew his movie was called
nope i was like you do that and he was
like he's like i don't know if i don't
want to tell tales out of school but he
basically was like it's all good man
like put it in and then when i watched
nope there is a very strong
note moment and i was like god damn it
dude but i
i like our moments i wouldn't have taken
it out anyway so it's all good but uh
anyway yeah right here
it was really hard to get this movie
made i you know a first time director
not known for anything but comedy uh
everybody said no it took me a year and
a half of no no no no i sent it to
everyone i knew i got knows and then i
got it to my buddies at boulder light
who are here and they
immediately they got it they said yes uh
they really championed me a lot and then
we got it to
uh roy lee who's here in the room and he
he really you know fought for me and
then i would say we financed the movie
independently and it our financier died
uh on the day of my going away party to
go to bulgaria to shoot the movie and
and they canceled like the movie was
over and uh
the miracle of miracles is that new
regency read the script like that day
and they got on zoom with me that
afternoon and that that they greenlit
the movie like they they saved us they
saved the movie it was like amazing and
um
and the best part is that uh
they were total champions and they
didn't they didn't [ __ ] with the movie
they were just like you you got a thing
the train's moving like let's not get in
way in the way of the train and it was
um
it was a real miracle like it really was
a miracle and oh what's crazy is after
they they greenlit the movie i called my
bulgarian line producers like we got the
money like we're back and he's like oh i
already fired everybody i already let
everybody go i was like oh it was like
the worst but then he he scrambled and
we got we got raised
thank you so much for waving over there
because i cannot see so yeah
um
i wanted to know
did you have any concerns about the meta
aspect of the movie there is a point at
which
uh aj is so horrible and she is so good
that you've got either she survives and
he dies or this is going to be a really
annoying movie
did you have any concerns about people
sort of going okay it's either gotta end
this way or i'm annoyed
no i i just don't think that way so i
didn't know um
i wish i had a more compelling
interesting answer but i just i didn't i
kind of just i wanted to write anything
that would satisfy me and so that's what
it is and i was just i just let that be
my north star and i i didn't think about
it really so that was always always your
ending yeah yeah i mean i knew that like
he wasn't gonna survive and she was
gonna die i knew that was not on the on
the table um so yeah if i can ask a
second question what happened to all of
the other
um because the gentleman who lives in
the junkyard is saying oh they're all of
these generations and that's not the
worst thing living in that house
so what happened to all of the other
things that he saw
he's when he says she's not the worst
thing in there he's
i i don't really like to get too deep
into like what is actually going on in
the movie but i mean he's he's referring
to frank
um
yeah
i always try and say like the the movie
that's advertised in the trailer is not
the movie that you're gonna see i don't
know that's true or not but that's
that's what i say to people uh
to manipulate them to get their money
yes
yeah yeah oh thank you
i i just think if you say don't
the less is more the less you know the
better going in you tell your friends
and tell all of your friends tell
acquaintances
tell people you haven't spoken to in a
long time people would think it's weird
that you're calling them
20 years i've been
i saw someone waving right yep
question
let's let's start down here and then
we'll we'll get to zach
well
i
i i i was confused by the title when i
first read it i no longer am um
but i uh it took a while it took me a
while like sitting with it even while we
were shooting it
um
but i always saw it as as uh
i i came to see it as i'm the i'm a bar
i'm the barbarian whoever is invade you
know the invader and it's i but it's
about i think more um the father frank
the idea of being invasive
and um
you know i take it to it it's extreme
as does the father uh he's but um yeah i
always saw it as that that idea
someone invading another
oppressing somebody
all of you uh
well i mean my manager is here and this
year as he's tried to pitch me for other
creature features he's been like he
plays the titular role in barbarians
and i was like i think i played the tit
chiller roll but not the titular role i
think when you see it you'll see
she's not the barbarian
i don't think
um
i don't really think about it that much
it
was the title of the movie it was cool
barbarian and
but i like weirdly got attached to it
and there was talk of changing the name
and i was like no like i was kind of
obsessed with it being called barbarian
so now that it is i'm happy yeah you
guys tell the real story well i mean
basically
ditto didn't what she said um i mean
it's
i i had to save the document um
i had to have a word to type to save it
or it would be untitled screenplay too
um so i wrote barbarian i think i'd
already written in my first kind of
session like barbary street and i i just
it seemed okay to me and then as i as i
finished i became attached to it and it
to me it feels it feels perfect um i've
had some really funny uh observations on
like the you could youtube comments
where some i saw one comment that was
like barbarian that's really smart
that's really smart
the the address is 476 barbary street
the year 476 is the year rome fell to
the barbarians and i was like is that is
that true and i like looked i was like
that is true i did not know that that's
crazy and i saw like another comment
that was like barbarian that's very
smart very smart barbarian is an anagram
of airbnb
i was like i didn't i didn't think about
that either that's [ __ ] scary to me
now i'm creeped out by myself
so i don't know that is incredible
um i am so sorry but we have to wrap it
up thank you guys so much for coming
thank you so much too lighter landmark
theaters 20th century studios please
tell your friends go see barbarian in
theater september 9. thank you guys so
much
you